okay [ __ ] we're back I don't like to
know what mission Ron anymore but it's
whatever Hannah it's whatever and I know
but actually knows what they're doing
okay great just great
just great I got channeling on one night
night night made for daddy daddy like a
oh sure and I want to [ __ ] it going
around fast
oh that a call has been it
ah this is [ __ ]
hello Cheryl
what's up [ __ ] it why is it like
rattling hole our place oh okay
happy doesn't I guess I thought that
this is the software the pen that make
this game IP software actually like made
originally this isn't like another
company bought the series I think and
they like P which invented percenter
tutors and like gaming after that okay
ooh nice ease Joanie Loves Chachi z' and
I'll bet it has a great smile like can
we get some little [ __ ] let me keep some
of this [ __ ] I'll take this helmet back
yo I'll take that cab luck yeah yeah
later
I'll take that I'll make my code I get
that you know luggage in here okay
it's not [ __ ] just reward of me now
happen now
shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ] [ __ ] this
suck a dick with that mouth [ __ ] I
didn't even know it's very kind law like
real what the [ __ ]
[Music]
yes fetch Wow
okay who's the one like shooting I don't
know where the [ __ ] I'm gone wow that
was great party it this combat sex so
easy like I'd also aim with the loss
trigger because they're so close like
you just go up to them and say like hey
we'd be like they're stuck on the end of
my barrel and they say like yes I care
like I love that okay no no where the
[ __ ] I'm gone yeah okay I must have
passed it
how can a tough [ __ ] is this how the
[ __ ] I'm here with the open somehow
don't my maids all I'm a don't mind me
babies okay in the Sun who we are one is
the Sun am i a [ __ ] myself office is
looking at right now hey guys I can't
[ __ ] mess it up them at I'm in the
wrong area
so that's about to [ __ ] be here
straight into the right
[ __ ] [ __ ] I got this one yet
I didn't go here yet can I cut through
them now okay I can't be go this far
back alright how's that I did explore
over here though what's my objective
look at the radio
okay yeah I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] what am i
doing all with me this is crazy Zach
this is cars it done here we go ah okay
I gotta figure how to get in there
[ __ ] okay be like this is the right
direction
[ __ ] a feel like I should be going
this way
so something here I also feel like I
should be going
oh there's a little Oh what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that is an honor and cap
there's one oh so much more battery
[Music]
at app app
yeah I need to keep moving or something
a [ __ ] hammer
fuckin'-a which is getting heated out
here oh [ __ ]
okay said I mean
overcharge my ass okay where all the
haters out
pretty good easy to aim without using
blocker
hey bro I want that and all that Oh chef
uh Cassata thank you thank you yeah I
said huh
there's a lot of [ __ ] people on this
level okay they're going to turn off
that alarm hey good luck I shut it away
the [ __ ] is that
what does all their lives okay what's
with all the bells and whistles and
there
that was refusing mature see my
paintball hair works yes we are raised
boys
okay boys is until awareness hello is
anyone there
it's your boy psychobabble kids in the
bed keep the Chunnel little bit blocked
when you're dead but sake just like no
you know you have their captain + quartz
this is the Eva sama and tarantula than
a few whole fleet as a nuclear comment
on this booth dimension our nuclear
Canada market at a year by Christoph
having some bonus here magnificent
[ __ ] you walk after me everybody
decryption keys to the new their
cannabis drinks in war fire another
nuclear warheads North here I was
planning Aram a big drop around among
term deficits throws so let's find the
corruption case the actual physical
nuclear decryption keys are not kept on
planet Earth
restored in the Nazi lunar base or
captain Atlanta by hacking the lunar
base the more secure facility than a
seized arms whether the other top-secret
research these days what's your point
Caroline and Anya what on a pocket each
care ok thing you will like a child
muscle soreness for the open places
connect so often I bet I can so I'm not
going to jail
there's no way this [ __ ] was made like
centers I gathered [ __ ] that [ __ ]
okay start David Wow there I guess that
is the purple in it I can add my white
Badgers my Prentice class I have waited
for this moment
there was things of August I won
Kentucky with the balance of the war
I can't century etiquette movie know
what exiled
hello I'm trying to see if this before
Fisher some outsider he could keep their
knowledge to the government who [ __ ]
offseason was home from the time I was
home still the Nazis brought the
evidence well there was no I remember
with this house you could we gather in
places like this it was blaming with
vice general deranged Rizzo and I think
them right is like in the red miracle
meet her
look for me in the rent maybe the last
to visit ah what the [ __ ] am i doing but
let me see mommy rubble rubble out will
be my stuff stuff inside Beckett boy
family what do you mean warning that
will make swamis in structures are old
and faded but this we used to get to the
main hall I don't recognize these
symbols
[Music]
[Applause]
all right you got a pebble in Moscowitz
I'll cover the rear all right
Oh
[Music]
see this is very very good place okay
[ __ ] can I feel like I should build a
jump right here okay I [ __ ] like that
show me your laser weapon please call
and I get out of [ __ ] water at it
half their way yeah uh yeah [ __ ] now
[ __ ] [ __ ] trap what the [ __ ]
okay hold on I have something for it
that this is just you could presume to
make your laser beam attuned to the
proper frequency walk off and should be
able to judge this magnetic coils you
see them up there I will going
okay so what do I do
okay I need instructions and I and I and
I charge again Ike I need more
instruction than that this allows the
[ __ ] hit the closed window
charge them up with my laser charge him
up with my laser he says oh there we go
okay now we're getting somewhere
okay
here we go this is making a little more
and the race is pretty complicated why
can't they just put a fifth button over
there
[Music]
so what exactly is like the technology
here we're gonna summon like a Jewish
God I get some words I think no you said
where where we got there now I don't
feel comfortable with that we're gonna
get squashed
okay well show me Polly
alright gentlemen I think that it's
useful to you you may take just remember
you are in a sacred space okay surely
constructions okay I guess that's not it
okay I'll give it a shot okay the first
is a pot which I've filmed the people
today detoxify and multiple abnormal
engages - Enrico's Paragon course of
play tough [ __ ]
genius was acquainted on a first-name
basis with God Almighty Himself oh well
we can only hope the most American turn
the plans in the future give a lot
everyone back home okay that now it
let's patch Roger I'm sufficiently
impressed
okay now let's patch [ __ ] okay ah this
thing and then this weird thing this guy
what is this like this hey put the gold
crown here first
oh okay that is level would you go
generally we have a lead on subscription
keys for the nuclear Canon onion
it's a troop transport train recall from
the African front on board is the chief
research scientist for depsite later
generations to personal destiny well
he's leaving for the mat-su toner-based
tonight to oversee the launch of the new
super Sudan they intercept the troop
transport train locates the chief
research scientist here his identity and
user to permit black college to take his
seat on the lunar shuttle until the
lunar base you need to find the nuclear
decryption keys and bring them back to
earth with intercept the high speed 93
transport rate best side will be the
Gibraltar bridge okay okay but hey we
can use this one this is very very
powerful
where in English you can call it
the spindly stalks you drop this in
front of the train successful stop any
exit if right away from the train
attempt ask me I know what you're
thinking blows cool no chance I'm
keeping this thing you give that to
Caroline okay and here